. Hallo, eins, zwei, drei, fünf. Wer synchronisiert, jetzt kann ich aber nicht mehr synchronisieren, weil ich kann jetzt nicht mehr so gut ranhalten, dann musst du jetzt ranhalten. Herzlich willkommen, sehr geehrte Damen und Herren. Und jetzt, jetzt. Herzlich willkommen, mein Name ist Günter Grebel, Sie hören die Synchronisation. Dankeschön. Ui, sogar ein bisschen mit Hall heute, ich habe heute das Fenster offen tatsächlich. Herzlich willkommen zum Podcast Ufo, Florentin hat sein Fenster offen. Hey, herzlich willkommen zu den Frühlingsgefühlen unter den Podcasts. Naja. Herzlich willkommen zu Stories Sat Poantenfeuerwerk. Vom Feins direkt vom Erzeuger. Ich sitze hier direkt, die Sonne scheint mir auf den entblößten Leib. Ich sitze gerade neben dem Fenster, das ich aufgemacht habe, ist mir tatsächlich auch gerade ein bisschen unangenehm, weil ich nicht weiß, ob die Leute im Hof mich so hören, ich mache es doch immer wieder bei Zug. Wo wohnst du, wohnst du im ersten Stock oder wohnst du noch? Im zweiten Stock. Ah, guck mal. Und da hat man, da lässt man da die Fenster schon offen, wenn man geht? Ja, ich tatsächlich schon, aber mein Mitbewohner ist da immer ein bisschen sehr skeptisch. Aber nicht, weil du es extra auflässt und weil du es vergisst einfach. Ja, genau. Und ich hatte mal ein sehr erleuchtendes Gespräch mit meinem Mitbewohner, als uns darüber unterhalten hat, weil er meinte, du sollst die Fenster nicht offen halten. Und dann meinte ich, ja warum denn nicht? Und dann meinte er, da kommen Einbrecher rein. Und dann habe ich gesagt, ja gut, aber wir sind im zweiten Stock, wie soll da ein Einbrecher reinkommen? Und dann enthielt seine Argumentation das Wort Enterhaken. Und ab da konnte ich ihn einfach nicht mehr ernst nehmen. Ab da konnte ich einfach kein ernsthaftes Gespräch mit ihm führen, weil er das Wort Enterhaken benutzt hat und da war es für mich aus. Da konnte kein logischer Argumentationspunkt mehr aufholen. Seitdem hast du auch die Türen aufgelassen einfach mal. Scheißegal, alles was er sagt macht keinen Sinn mehr. Hörst du das? Was höre ich? Du trinkst. Du schlürfst, schlürfst und trinkst und... Ja, und zwar war das ganz Besonderes, und zwar habe ich heute Booster im Glas. Booster warm gemacht in der Tasse. Genau, ich habe es warm gemacht, ein bisschen, und ich habe nämlich die eingeflaschte Form von Booster gefunden, tatsächlich. Die 1,5 Liter Flasche für den Riesenboost. Also boost ihr Booster, wenn ihr der normale Booster noch nicht genug boostet, dann boost ihn einfach. Weißt du, was mir die Augen geöffnet hat? Dass man halt in Tee ja auch Milch reinmachen kann. Das habe ich sehr spät in meinem Leben erfahren, also zu spät eigentlich. Und da hat man die Augen geöffnet. Seitdem überlege ich die ganze Zeit, wo man überall Milch reinmachen könnte. Vielleicht ist auch so Energydrinks oder so Booster mit Milch einfach total geil. Ist wahrscheinlich eine ganz gute Idee. Was ich ja tatsächlich mal durchsetzen wollte, war Pfefferminzmilch. Also Milch mit Pfefferminz-Sirup. Schmeckt auch tatsächlich ähnlich widerlich, wie man es erwarten würde. Von daher, glaube ich, sind da alle Rätsel gelöst. Aber es ist doch alles, was man durchsetzen will, muss ja auch nicht unbedingt immer gut sein. Man kann sich aber das zum Ziel machen, einfach mal, weil man sich sehr auf ein Challenge setzen will, mal was durchzusetzen, was vielleicht scheiße ist von vornherein. Dinge, die jeder will, zu verkaufen, das kann jeder, das ist kein Problem, das ist kein Problem. Aber was ich mir zum Beispiel auch dachte, man kann ja auch, also ich habe andersrum gedacht als du, ich habe zum Beispiel gedacht, man macht ja Tee mit Wasser, und könnte man nicht statt Wasser noch andere Dinge nehmen, um Tee zu machen. Man macht zum Beispiel einen Energydrink, kocht man auf und schüttelt dann schön mit Pfeffer. Oh Jesus, geht gerade Musik bei mir an überall. Okay, sorry. Mein fucking Virus, ey, ohne Scheiß. Ich würde auch sagen, Bluetooth hat nicht alles besser gemacht. Auch wenn man eine Taste drückt, geht überall irgendwas an in meiner Wohnung. Geht im Nachbarzimmer die Musik an. Genau, in einer anderen Wohnung geht es plötzlich Musik an, das Nachbarn kommen. Das Klavier vom Nachbarn hört man plötzlich auf seinen Kopfhörern und man weiß gar nicht, wie das funktioniert. Es ist furchtbar, furchtbar. Ich bin auch nicht mehr durch, die ganze Technik setzt einen dann schon irgendwie auch. Es ist zu viel, es ist einfach zu viel Technik. Nee, aber tatsächlich, ich glaube, ich habe das tatsächlich noch nie ausprobiert, aber ich glaube auch nicht, dass das gut funktioniert mit Energy, also mit Tee und anderen Sachen.
Ich glaube auch, Energy aufzukochen ist, glaube ich, gefährlich. Also ich habe das Gefühl, Energydrinks haben für mich was ganz Gefährliches. Zu viel Joule, also zu viel reine physische Energie ist. Ich glaube, mit Energydrinks kann man auch zum Beispiel einen Tank befüllen und es würde halt sich nichts ändern. Das wäre halt ein sehr teures Benzin, würde ich sagen. Man darf Energy Drink auch auf keine zu grössen Höhen mitnehmen, weil einfach die Energie, die darauf wirkt, die potenzielle Energie, die es dann dadurch bekommt, durch die Kraft, die man aufwendet, ist, auf diese Höhe zu bringen, ist zu krass. Es wird zu viel Energie. Wo drin ist mehr Energie, in Energydrinks oder in Magneten eigentlich? Ich glaube, Magneten haben einfach unlimited power, da kommst du nicht mit. Wo wir bei unserem heutigen Thema wären. Ich glaube, in so einem kleinen Magneten ist mehr Energie drin als in einer Atombombe, das ist einfach, da kannst du nicht mithalten. Das ist mir klar, aber das hat sich auch nicht. Damit wollen wir unseren Zugehörern aber jetzt auch nicht irgendwie auf die Synapsen belasten. Apropos Synapsen? Ja. Ja, mach weiter. Ich mach für dich die Überleitungen. Dankeschön. Nee, wir wollen heute über Chancen reden. Was sind die Chancen dieses Podcasts? Ach, Chancen? Ich dachte Chanson. Chanson. Ich habe jetzt komplett Chanson vorbereitet. Du hast dich jetzt komplett französische Chanson-Geschichte eingeprägt. Ich habe die ganze Nacht Elit Piaf gehört. Verdammt nochmal, wofür? Ja, dann hältst du gleich kurz... Je ne regrette rien. Mach gleich ein kurzes Impulsreferat und sing halt einen kleinen Auszug vielleicht, um ein bisschen zu den Gefühlen näher zu bringen. Aber ich wollte über Chancen reden. Speziell auch, ich würde auch gerne mit Perspektiven dieses Podcasts sprechen, weil ich habe mich mal, ich habe jetzt neulich mal das Wort Empathie gelernt und ich habe mir mal überlegt, ich habe es mal angewandt und was würden Leute, die unseren Podcast hören, was haben die davon? Die brauchen einen Mehrwert meines Erachtens und ich habe den nicht gefunden. Ich habe mir unsere Folgen angehört und ich habe keinen Mehrwert gefunden. Ich fand es nicht besonders gut,
sage ich ganz offen. Ich war mit uns nicht zufrieden
und jetzt will ich mir überlegen,
was hat der Hörer im Endeffekt davon?
Ich würde gerne ein bisschen wissen. Einmal habe ich
Licht erklärt, super gut.
Von dir kam nichts.
Die 40 Sekunden, in denen du Licht erklärt hast, waren glaube ich das
absolute Highlight. Ich glaube, der Zuschauer
hat zu viel
von Qualitätscontent. Einfach, man hat so viel Qualitätscontent. Es gibt zu viele gute Sachen einfach. HD-Videos überall und ich glaube, der sehnt sich einfach nach ein bisschen Mittelmässigkeit, auch Content, mit dem man sich identifizieren kann. Da hast du so einen Jan Böhrmann, der redet perfekt, der macht keine Fehler, der verspricht sich nicht, jeder Gag sitzt. Da denkt man okay, was soll ich damit? Ja, das ist genau wie Superman. Niemand mag Superman, man mag Batman. Da sind die Eltern tot. Wieso soll das kein Booster mehr trinken beim Aufnehmen? Du machst so komische Pausen an so ganz komischen Stellen, weil du aufstoßen musst oder so. Du machst so ganz komische Pausen, so mitten im Wort. Ja, aber weißt du, damit können sich die Leute identifizieren. Die Leute sagen, ja, ich bin auch manchmal scheiße und ich bin auch manchmal ganz am Boden und mir geht es auch manchmal schlecht. Ich kriege auch keinen Satz gerade aus. Ich bin auch manchmal ein emotionales Wrack. So, und dann können die Leute auch da sich mit identifizieren. Ich weiß nicht, ich glaube, wir sind so eine Art Spiegel-Podcast, auch so ein bisschen, denen geht es noch beschissener als uns, Ding, was die Leute auch immer ganz gern sehen eigentlich. Ja, okay, aber hast du, wollen wir mal Perspektiven reden oder hast du eben schon einen Gag zum Thema? Ich sehe keine Perspektive. Okay, aber du hast halt schon deinen einen Gag zum Thema Chancen, hast du schon rausgehauen? Ja, ich weiß nicht genau, welchen Gag du meinst, aber fahr einfach mal fort. Den Chanson-Gag. Ach so, ja, damit hat es sich für mich schon erledigt. Hast du auch immer so ein kleines Texteditorfeld vor dir, wo genau drei Wörter drinstehen, mit denen du krampfhaft versuchst, über eine Stunde wegzureden.
Ja, vor allem bei mir stehen irgendwie drei kurze Sätze zum Podcast und dann 80 Twitter-Tweet-Entwürfe, die ich eigentlich genommen habe. Zum Beispiel, alles hat seinen Preis und darunter wie so ein Zitat von Preisschild. Hat es nicht geschafft, tatsächlich in die Twittersphäre. Aber zu Recht auch. Ich habe eben dieser, der Fussball muss ein wahnsinnig guter Autor gewesen sein. Ja, fand ich nicht so gut. Du hast mir eine Fünf gegeben dafür. Ich glaube, wenn man das versteht, man sagt ja auch, der Fussball schreibt die beste Spannende Geschichten. Ja, aber wenn man das versteht, ist das doch ein guter Gag, glaube ich. Nee, ich glaube, das ist zu nahe. Ich glaube, das ist ein Gag, auf den kommen zu viele Leute. Ich sollte aufhören, auf dich zu hören. Ja, absolut. Ich sollte aufhören, auf jemanden zu hören, der eigentlich so das in Englisch übersetzt. Das ist zum Beispiel so kleine wissenswerte Dinge, die man nach außen geben kann. So kleine Lebensweisheiten, die wir mit unseren jeweils 18 Jahren mittlerweile schon raushaben. Hört nicht auf andere und dann habt ihr ein besseres Leben. So das sind diese Weisheiten, die man wahrscheinlich auch raommt. Hört auf euch selbst, hört nicht auf Leute in Podcasts, sondern hört auf euch selbst, hört auf euer Herz.
Ich habe heute den sinnlosen Protest aller Zeiten gesehen. Berlin ist ja eine hochpolitische Stadt und wenn man da durch die Straßen geht, man kommt ja aus der Demokratie nicht mehr raus. Die hängt sich ein Jahr an den Rockzipfel, da kommt man ja nicht von weg. An jeder Ecke wird protestiert, überall Plakate hängen, Mindestlohn, weniger Atomenergie, mehr Atomenergie, weniger Lohn, immer hin und her. Es ist alles wahnsinnig polarisiert, diese ganze Stadt B pulsiert vor politischer Kraft. Aber heute bin ich Zeuge eines Protests geworden, wo ich wirklich den Hut gezogen habe und gesagt habe, wow, da ist wirklich was passiert, das wird der historische Moment. Und zwar haben protestiert fünf Rentner, zwei davon mit Megafonen, die gleichzeitig aber andere Dinge gesprochen haben, was schon mal sehr irritierend war.
Auch gegensätzliche Dinge, weil sie sich nicht genau einig wurden, was sie da sagen wollen.
Nein, Rita, wir sind dafür. Nein, wir sind dagegen. Und dann machen wir jetzt eben zwei Proteste von mir aus.
Oder auch so plötzlich so Privatgespräche übers Megafon ausgetragen werden. Genau, nee, wir sind auf einer Demonstration, aber jeder kann seine eigene Meinung sagen. Ist ja ein freies Land. Und dann einfach so Singchöre und alle sagen das Gegenteil. Auf jeden Fall haben sie demonstriert vor, und ich wusste ehrlich gesagt gar nicht, dass dieses Gebäude zwei Strassen von mir entfernt war, von meiner Wohnung. Und zwar haben sie gegen protestiert, gegen die Botschaft von Nordkorea. Korea. Zwei Strassen weiter von mir entfernt war, von meiner Wohnung. Und zwar haben sie gegen protestiert, gegen die Botschaft von Nordkorea.
Zwei Strassen weiter von mir,
wo ich wohne, ist tatsächlich die Botschaft von
Nordkorea irgendwie, demokratische
Volksrepublik, irgendwie
Nordkorea.
Und davor haben die protestiert, also fünf
Rentner gegen Nordkorea. Mir ist aufgefallen, in Berlin, da sind
total viele Botschaften und die sind alle
so ein bisschen klischeehaft. Also diese ägyptische Botschaft sieht aus wie so ein Riesensarkophag. Ist eine Pyramide. Ist so ein bisschen wie Las Vegas. Die französische ist so ein Eiffelturm. Ja, und diese skandinavischen Botschaften sind alle so super bis das letzte Detail ausdesignt, so mega. Genau, so Licht durchflutet, so hölzverdacht. Ja, total. auch total transparent und friedlich. Dann die Schweizer Botschaft, einfach versteckt, einfach so ein kleiner Käseblock. Nein, aber es sind total klischeehaft. Löcher drin, so ein bisschen, ja. Ja, diese arabische Botschaft, die hat dann außen so krasse Mosaik-Teile, die so verziert und so halt mega arabische Schriftzeichen. Riesigen Sprengstoffgürtel ums Gebäude rum. Ich finde, das ist echt total klischeehaft, diese Gebäude. Ja, es ist auch tatsächlich. Ja, es ist auch tatsächlich. Die amerikanische... England sieht aus wie so eine grosse Teetasse. Genau, die amerikanische Botschaft ist so ein Plantagenhaus. Ui. Ja. Und dann haben die dagegen demonstriert, gegen die Existenz von Nordkorea demonstriert. Nee, die haben gegen das nordkoreanoreanische Regime protestiert. Die haben dann irgendwie Abschaffung von Zwangslagern und Straflagern und so. Und sie auch denkt so, ja Leute, ist ja cool, dass ihr euch dafür einsetzt, aber das bringt halt gar nichts. Also gar nichts, überhaupt nichts. Die wollen dann ihre Meinung mal kundtun. Ja, aber dass man gegen Straflager ist, das muss man auch nicht sagen. Das ist doch selbstverständlich.
Lass uns mal bitte gegen den Tod demonstrieren. Wir mögen den Tod nicht. Aber ich finde auch gut, Demokratie hat halt so viele kleine Aspekte, wofür man auch gegen Dinge demonstrieren darf und soll auch, gegen die man nichts tun kann. Also warum nicht mal gegen den Tod demonstrieren oder gegen schlechte Sachen auf der Welt? Ich bin gegen Schlechtigkeit
zum Beispiel, gegen Negativität.
Das ist eine gute Idee. Ich bin
gegen, bin einfach dagegen.
Du hast also
die dümmste Demonstration gesehen, ich habe die dümmste
Werbung der Welt gesehen auf Twitter,
das ist echt ganz schön geil.
Also da ist
eine Spielwerbung, du kennst ja diese gesponserten Tweets und Also da ist eine Spielwerbung, kennst du diese gesponserten Tweets? Und dann steht da so eine Spielwerbung und die endet damit, also die bewirbt das Spiel und die endet damit, versuche es, warum nicht? Unenthusiastische, ja, why not? Ich musste wahnsinnig lachen. Also wie muss so eine Werbereaktionskonferenz, wie muss die enden, damit man auf den Satz kommt, versuche es, warum nicht, hey, warum nicht. Es gibt ja keinen Grund gegen unser Produkt. Wie verzweifelt muss man sein, warum nicht als Werbung, als einziger der treffende Grund. Werbung muss ja mit dem besten Grund für das Produkt irgendwie enden. Und der letzte Punkt
muss ja der stärkste sein. Ja, also
der stärkste Punkt muss man sein,
damit der stärkste Punkt ist,
warum nicht? Hey,
du hast nichts zu verlieren. Wenn das
beste Argument ist, dass es keine
Gegenargumente gibt, dann hast du ein Problem.
Ich sehe schon die T-Shirts,
das Podcast-UFO, warum nicht?
Warum nicht? Lass uns. Hey, warum nicht? Ja, auch nicht. Warum? Naja. Da muss ich sehr lachen. Ja, okay, also mein Textdokument ist genau jetzt abgearbeitet. Ich habe tatsächlich noch eins, und zwar Tauben im Zoo, weil auch in einem Zoo gibt es ja wahrscheinlich Tauben, die aber frei sind und trotzdem im Zoo sind. Genau wie diese Faunen, die da immer rumlaufen. Ja, nee, aber jetzt also Tiere, die im Zoo sind, aber nicht im Zoo leben. So Besuchertiere, wie so halt Tauben, die da halt mal vorbeichecken. Und dann, also sind die neidisch auf die Vögel in Käfigen, weil die halt dann total krasse exotische Vögel sind, oder fühlen die sich gut und so teasen die auch so ein bisschen, die Vögel, die eingesperrt sind? Oder demonstrieren die da gerade auf ihre Taubenart gegen die Existenz von Zoos? Ja, und wir verstehen das noch nicht. Das habe ich auch noch nicht ganz verstanden. Das ist auch egal. Wie müssen wir eigentlich als liberale, tolerante Menschen, wie müssen wir eigentlich Zoos finden? Also ich finde Zoos per se erstmal nicht schlecht, aber es ist ja auch oft, ist es ja im Mittelpunkt der Kritik. Wirklich ist es oft im Mittelpunkt der Kritik. Da kann man einfach so drauf los sagen. Es ist ja sehr umstritten. Ja, kann sein, keine Ahnung. Aber ich finde, es gibt manche Themen, wo es einfach so eine Meinung gibt und das ist dann halt so die Meinung. Das sind so langweilige Themenige Themen, das ist irgendwie so Massentierhaltung so. Ja, natürlich ist das scheiße. Bist du dann auch per se immer dafür, also bist du gegen ein, bist du dann, nimmst du dann die oppositionelle Meinung an? Total. Einfach um so ein bisschen Abwechslung reinzubringen, so ein bisschen Diskurs anzuregen in der Öffentlichkeit. Sagst du dann, du versuchst dann zwanghaft nach Gründen für Massentierhaltung zu beibringen. Ja, absolut, absolut. Ich dachte mir, wenn die, je beschisseneres Leben die führen, desto eher wollen die getötet werden. Und desto besser ist es, sie zu töten. Oder man kann auch sagen, die wissen ja nicht, dass man auch ein schönes Leben haben kann. Ja, genau, genau. Also Deswegen wäre es sogar fatal, die freizulassen, weil sie dann denken würden, Alter, die ersten zwei Jahre meines Lebens habe ich hier richtig scheiße gelebt. Das hätte ich machen können, und dann sind die total depressiv. Ich kann jetzt zum Beispiel, ich habe diese Meinung jetzt so stark angenommen schon, dass ich nicht mehr Leute verstehen kann, die ernsthaft gegen Massentierhaltung demonstrieren. Ja, vielleicht mögen die Tiere das ja auch, man weiß es ja nicht. Man kann ja mit denen nicht kommunizieren, vielleicht mögen die das ja. Das mögen ja auch manche Menschen, mögen es ja, verletzt zu werden oder geschlagen zu werden. Warum mögen die? Warum sollen wir eigentlich die Tiere bevormunden? Warum sollen wir eigentlich entscheiden, was die Tiere gefällt und was nicht? Das wäre echt geil, wenn da so SM-Tiere dabei sind, alle sind total down und so drei von hundert Küken sind unfassbar, finden das total geil und feiern das total. Und alle so, was habt ihr eigentlich, was ist euer fucking Problem, dass ihr das feiert? Wir werden unterdrückt, wir leben in ein Quadratzentimeter Scheisskäfigen und wir müssen zwei Eier pro Tag legen, warum feiert er da so? Und das einfach so, die einen unerklärlichen Fetisch haben dafür. So geht das, wenn die Welt positiv sehen. Du hast immer gesagt, du hast eine Geschichte noch zu erzählen. Aber bist du eigentlich jemand, der Chancen ergreift? Also bist du so jemand, der, wenn er eine Situation sieht, wo er wirklich jetzt Profit schlagen könnte, dann zugreift? Also bist du jemand, der Chancen am Schopf packt?
Ich bin zumindest jemand, der gerne opportunistisch agiert.
Also wenn ich sehe, dass Leute die Chance ergreifen und dass schlaue Leute sind und
die in der Mehrzahl sind, würde ich sofort die Chance auch ergreifen.
Wenn mir eine Chance vor die Füße gelegt würde, von der ich nicht genau weiß, wie
ich die finden soll, dann würde ich erstmal vorsichtig sein. Ich würde erstmal mich
in schneller Sitz davor legen und
meditieren über diese Chance.
Aber du zum Beispiel, du bist ja
ein Mensch, der sehr von Chancen profitiert
hat, schon in deinem Leben.
Absolut. Du hast von Entscheidungen profitiert,
die ich nicht ganz nachvollziehbar finde.
Also du wurdest
in so Moderationskreise aufgenommen, wo ich
in der Jury gesessen hätte und gesagt, laut gelacht hätte, wenn ich dich gesehen hätte. Ja. Aber da musst du doch sehr dankbar sein. Also du musst... Ich bin tatsächlich da sehr dankbar, aber so eine Chance kommt natürlich auch mit einer grossen Verantwortung einher, dass man sagt, mach was draus, wenn man diese Chance... Jetzt zitieren wir ihn beides im Sinne von Spider-Man. Wir sind echt Kings. Nein, nicht aus grosser Macht, sondern aus grosser Chance. Ja, leicht abgeändert. Habe ich gesagt, leicht abgeändert. das reicht. Für einen Tweet würde es reichen. Passt schon. Da hast du wirklich die Hemmschwelle abgelegt, irgendwas zu gucken. Absolut, ja. Ich bin mittlerweile so verzweifelt. Ich wandle nur noch irgendwie allgemeine Floskeln, nur leicht ab. Wer anderen einen Graben trägt, fällt selbst hinein. So, das haue ich raus. Du hattest eine krasse Twitter-Krise, kann man ja mal sagen. Ich hatte eine enorme Twitter-Krise. In zehn Jahren wird man da vor den Geschichtsbüchern sitzen, da gab es die grosse Kuba-Krise, eine andere Krise und die Twitter-Krise. Die wird sich später in den Geschichtsbüchern schaffen. Du hast echt nichts zustande bekommen, oder? Ich hatte echt einen krassen Twitter-Lauf und ich habe es vielleicht auch ein bisschen übertrieben, ich habe vielleicht zu viel rausgehauen, ich hätte vielleicht noch ein bisschen mehr nach, aber da können wir gleich mal ganz kurz über Kreativtheorie sprechen. Also angenommen, Über Chancen, über Chancen, die die Kreativität gibt. Ja, von mir aus. Wir müssen uns alles irgendwie mit der Brechstange auf das Thema zubiegen. Also, lass mich nur ein Beispiel finden, mit dem man das gut veranschaulichen kann. Sagen wir mal, du hast diesen Podcast hier,
ja, und
jetzt hast du aber eine gute Story,
jetzt hast du aber,
sagen wir mal, in zwei Wochen
bist du in einem anderen Podcast eingeladen,
in einem, der hunderttausend Hörer hat.
Und jetzt willst du natürlich die guten
Geschichten auch für diesen grösseren Podcast
aufheben. Naja, oder?
Ja, aber jetzt gibt es zwei Kreativtheorien.
Ich nenne sie mal die Hamstertheorie
und ich nenne sie die Fabriktheorie.
Und die Hamstertheorie besagt,
halt deine guten Sachen eher zurück,
bis eine Situation kommt, in der
du sie wirklich gut einsetzen kannst,
wohingegen die Fabriktheorie sagt,
je mehr du raushaust,
desto besser wird deine Fabrik und
je mehr Content durch dich durchfließt,
desto mehr Stories und Gags
du raushaust, desto besser werden die nächsten Gags.
Also die Gags, die du jetzt für lustig reißt. Die dritte Theorie, ja, hat man verstanden. Aber die dritte Theorie gibt es auch noch, das ist die Beta-Theorie, dass du es erst in dem kleinen Podcast testest. Ja, aber da kommt man natürlich auch mit der ... Du teest, du versuchst es nochmal, vielleicht kannst du es nachher nochmal abändern, du guckst, was funktioniert, was kam gut an, wo haben die Leute selbst im kleinen Podcast schon geschrieben, wow, hey, Florentin, das war eine gute Geschichte. Ja, aber jetzt angenommen, alle, die den kleinen Podcast hören, hören auch den großen Podcast. Und alle deine Fans aus dem kleinen Podcast würden mitbekommen, wenn du dem großen Podcast die gleiche Story nochmal erzählst. Du fragst gerade für einen Freund, oder bist du dem nicht echt im grossen Podcast? Nee, nee, ich frage nur für einen Freund.
Ein bisschen Angst, ein bisschen sehe ich meine Fälle schwimmen.
Und da
weiß man eben nicht, wie man es angehen soll,
weil man hätte, also das ist ja generell
ein Konzept, das sich generell auf alles
übertragen lässt.
Also wenn man jetzt mit jemandem sich
unterhält und man weiß, man wird sich noch häufiger
mit der Person unterhalten und man hat fünf gute Storys, denkt man dann, okay, ich haue jetzt eine raus und beim nächsten Treffen dann die zweite.
Oder denkt man, ich haue jetzt alle fünf raus mit dem Wissen, dass die Nächsten besser werden als die ersten fünf, weil ich ja immer besser in Stories erzählen werde. Okay, also da kann ich dir folgenden Rat geben, es gibt nämlich dann den tollen, ich nenne mal den Florentin-Will-Weg, einfach sich Geschichten irgendwann zu klauen von anderen und die dann dementsprechend so rauszuholen, als wären es die eigenen, die auch gerne früher erzählten Geschichten komplett widersprechen können.
Oder man sagt einfach, man ist einfach mal der Mensch, Florentin will.
Du bist einfach mal der Mensch.
Du redest einfach mal keine Anekdoten runter, sondern du redest einfach mal, du bist einfach mal menschlich und zeigst mal so eine Seite deinen wirklichen Körper. Ja, aber das interessiert ja niemanden.
Ja, das stimmt.
Eben.
Ich meine, kannst du dich noch an die eine Folge erinnern, als wir mal Mensch waren, als wir wirklich ernsthaft geredet haben, als wir uns geöffnet haben, über unsere Gefühle geredet haben, was du erstens alles rausgeschnitten hast. Du meinst die Folge, wo du über deine Pornos gesprochen hast. Bei deinem Pornokonsum. Wo du mal einmal ehrlich warst. Da ging es nicht nur um Porno, da ging es um Liebe und echte Gefühle und tiefste innere Gefühle, da ging es um alles. Hast du alles rausgeschnitten und es wurde nicht gesendet und es wäre wahrscheinlich auch nicht gut angekommen. Aber gut, das ist natürlich noch was anderes. Ein Podcast und ein persönliches Gespräch ist natürlich noch was anderes. Aber trotzdem, es ist ja auch dabei, du kannst ja dich als Mensch nicht ohne Content präsentieren. Du kannst ja am Content gewisse Charakterzüge oder über dich selber sprechen. Aber ohne geht's ja nicht. Wenn du einfach nichts hast, worüber du reden kannst, dann hast du einfach keine Plattform, auf der du aufbauen kannst. Oder du hast einfach kein Leben. Weil also, wenn du einfach ein normales Leben leben würdest, dann hast du auch Dinge zu erzählen. Ja, wie zum Beispiel, dass ich heute einen Protest gesehen habe gegen die nordkoreanische Botschaft. Okay, und genau da ist es erschöpft. Ja, da ist es erschöpft, genau, das war es dann auch. Und da kann man auch nicht viel dazu sagen, so, ja, cool. Na gut, wir hätten jetzt eine halbe Stunde darüber reden können, gegen was man noch protestieren könnte, könnte, zum Beispiel. Gegen den Tod hätten wir zum Beispiel sagen können, wir hätten einfach die interessante humoristische Beobachtung machen können, dass man gegen Dinge demonstriert, die man nicht ändern kann. Sehr gut, gute Idee, warum sind wir da nicht drauf gekommen? Wollen wir eigentlich heute unsere Rubrik wieder machen mit dem ersten Menschen? Oh nee, da bin ich nicht vorbereitet. Die kam super an. Die kam total gut an, es kam auch super, wir können ja mal ein bisschen auf die Community eingehen, obwohl ich jetzt leider meinen Browser schließen musste, was der einzige Grund ist, warum keine Community-Arbeit stattfindet. Es kam auch tatsächlich cooler Input von der Community. Und zwar der Input kommt von der Cam, ah hier, von Fabian. Fabian schreibt, der erste Mensch, der den Penis eines anderen beschnitten hat. Sehr, sehr geil. Hat mir sehr gut gefallen. Vielen Dank dafür. Ja, mir auch. Erstmal einen kurzen Applaus. Fabian. Fabian. Vielleicht hat sie die Person aber auch selbst beschnitten. Was? Vielleicht hat sie die Person aber auch selbst beschnitten. Oder sie kam beschnitten zur Welt und man hat gesagt, das ist geil, das ist ein cooler Style, der gefällt mir, so will ich es auch, mach mir das mal. Und es war einfach mega unspektakulär. Wie ist das eigentlich mit Beschneidung? Bist du eigentlich beschnitten? Ich finde, lass uns so eine Top Ten aller Fragen stellen, die man vielleicht im Interview nicht als erstes stellen sollte, beziehungsweise überhaupt nicht stellen sollte. Ja, vor allem Frauen nicht. Sind sie beschnitten? Frauen sollte man nicht fragen, bist du eigentlich beschnitten? Ja, das stimmt. Das ist ein guter Punkt, ja. Also, komm, ich mach mal die Liste kurz. Ich schreib die mal einfach auf. Ich weiß nicht, wann ich die Nummer brauche, wahrscheinlich nie, aber ich schreib's mal auf. Also Top5 Dinge, die man in einem Interview niemals fragen sollte.
Platz 1.
Sind sie beschnitten.
Beim Spechterkulär ist es Platz 1 an und enden dann mit etwas langweiligem Platz 4.
Ist auch immer gut, mit der 1 anzufangen, um sich dann langsam runterzuarbeiten.
Da bleiben die Leute knallhart dran.
Boah, ich muss sehen, was noch ein bisschen schlechter als Nummer vier ist.
Platz fünf.
Ist das schon die Platz fünf?
Ich würde sagen, Platz vier haben sie einen Freund.
Bist du eigentlich beschnitten?
Du musst es nicht mehr aufschreiben. Egal, so die Shownotes. Das ist auch geil. So, wir können ja mal eine Platz fünf, Top fünf Liste aufstellen von Dingen, die man im Podcast nicht machen sollte. Das werden wir einfach mitschreiben, so die ganzen Podcasts die ganze Zeit so protokollieren. Bei Platz fünf zum Beispiel, bei Platz eins wir beginnen zum Beispiel, das sind so Dinge, die man nicht machen sollte.
Also Platz fünf, bist du da nicht beschnitten, Platz vier hast du einen Freund, Platz drei finde ich die kritische Frage, hast du da nicht Haustiere? Das kann aber auch ein Icebreaker sein, das kann tatsächlich ein Icebreaker sein. Bei Oli P hat es super funktioniert. Hat auch gar nicht dazu geführt, dass wir die ganze Zeit bei so einem Hundethema stecken geblieben sind. Ja, uns überhaupt nicht über den Menschen Oli P genähert haben. Das ist echt das Ding. Ich habe mal gehört, man braucht immer ein Ziel, ein Interviewziel. Und mein Ziel war bislang immer, den Menschen kennenzulernen, der dahinter steckt. Du kannst ja mal mich interviewen. Da können wir beide Themen gleich verbinden. Das ist ohne Scheiß so. Ich muss für eine Projektarbeit, ich komme mir vor wie so eine Waldorfschule, wir müssen ja so eine Projektarbeiten, so ganz komisches schreiben. Also eins ist davon, ich muss aufnehmen, wie ich ja meine interviewe.
Und ich habe echt überlegt, dass hier live im Podcast-Dubes machen muss. Ja, mach das doch, machen wir das doch einfach jetzt.
Machen wir das doch genau jetzt.
Naja, ich muss das ja vorbereiten und es soll wirklich gut sein.
Scheiße drauf, du würdest das nicht vorbereiten.
Es muss wirklich drei Minuten sein, ich kriege eine Note nach.
Drei Minuten?
Ja, es ist nicht so viel.
Das ist überhaupt nichts.
Das ist eine halbe Frage.
Wenn du schälst die Frage zur Hälfte, dann unterbreche ich dich drei Minuten lang. Und das ist das Interview. Okay, Achtung, wir fangen jetzt an. Okay. Das ist noch mit einer Moderation und so. Herzlich willkommen heute zur Sendung XYZ. Heute bei mir Florentin Will. Hallo, schön, dass ich da sein kann. Ich danke mir jetzt mal, dass Sie, ja gerne, ja würde ich auch hoffen, dass Sie da sind. Also das reiht mich auch gewundertundert. Florentin Will, haben Sie eigentlich Haustiere? Ich habe im Grunde schon Haustiere, allerdings nicht welche, mit denen ich momentan zusammenlebe. Du musst jetzt drei Minuten reden. Allerdings, in meinem Elternhaus gibt es noch ein Haustier, eine kleine Katze, die kenne ich seit ihrer Geburt. Und ich bin aber jetzt ausgezogen, lebe alleine und habe jetzt hier keinen Haustier mehr. Aber in meinem Herzen gibt es noch ein Haustier, eine kleine Katze, die kenne ich seit ihrer Geburt und ich bin aber jetzt ausgezogen, lebe alleine und habe jetzt hier kein Haustier mehr, aber in meinem Herzen gibt es noch ein Tier. Der Mensch Florentin Will, wie muss man sich den vorstellen? Der Mensch Florentin Will ist leer, einsam und ängstlich. Ist das der Grund, warum Florentin Will sich so eine Art Rolle, eine Maske, verschiedene Schalen um sich herum aus Anekdoten, Geschichten und Bezügen in die Vergangenheit, in die Zukunft, in die Surrealität baut. Das ist genau der Grund. Ich versuche die innere Lehre, die mich jeden Tag foltert, mit Heiterkeit und Stimmung zu füllen. Das gelingt mir allerdings nicht immer. Ist das der Grund, warum Sie selber quasi, ich zitiere, sich als einen Donut bezeichnen? Richtig, ich sehe das menschliche Persönlichkeitsmodell wie ein Donut, in dem eine innere Lebe kraft.
Ganz kurz, da würde ich gerne unterbrechen, sehen Sie sich selber als ein Donut oder die ganze Menschheit und alle Charaktermodelle eines Menschen?
Ich sehe sowohl mich als auch die gesamte Menschheit als Donut.
Also würden Sie sich schon selber als ein Mensch bezeichnen?
Ja.
Dankeschön für das Gespräch, Führerin Will.
Gerne.
Nächste Woche zu Gast niemand, denn es ist nur für ein einmaliges Projektarbeit.
Ich bedanke mich.
Vielen Dank, dankeschön, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Ja, war doch gut.
Ja, würde ich auch sagen.
Super, super gut.
Muss ich auch sagen.
Hey, hey, hey.
Ich finde es in der Natur der Länge.
Wo man Dinge plötzlich besser macht, als man dachte.
Platz vier.
Platz Nummer drei.
Waren Sie eigentlich schon mal, ach ja, waren Sie eigentlich schon mal lustig, würde ich
sagen, Platz drei.
Oder sollte das ein Witz sein? Als erste Frage. Meinen Sie das ernst? Genau. Ist dieses Outfit Ihr ernst? Sind das Ihre echten Haare? Die Nase ist doch ein Witz. Wollen Sie noch Mario dazu? Wollen Sie noch Mario zu den Haaren? Keine Ahnung. Das Gespräch zum Mitnehmen oder zum Geheißen? Genau. Beleidigungen, die auch überhaupt keinen Sinn ergeben. Aber es ist ein bisschen dieses Between-to-Ferns-Modell, ne? Ja. Ja, okay. Oh, oh, oh, es kam aber, als ob es die ganze Zeit irgendwie raus wollte aus dir. Ja, es ist genau das. Ich habe mich tatsächlich ein bisschen mit Go Butler beschäftigt. Ach, echt? Weil wir ein bisschen darüber geredet haben. Du hast es mir in der letzten Folge empfohlen und ich habe es mir jetzt auch geholt und ich benutze es eigentlich nicht, glaube ich, nicht so wie es gedacht ist, und zwar, dass man dem irgendwie Aufgaben gibt, sondern ich stelle dem nur Fragen, ich stelle dem nur Fragen, aber auch so ganz persönliche Fragen. Was man auch einfach bei Google eingeben könnte, aber hey, ich will dafür 19 Cent von der SMS raushauen. Wirklich? Das kostet 19 Cent. Ja, es ist halt eine normale SMS, die du da schickst. Ist das normal? Bei mir aber mehr. Ich habe einen ganz schlechten Handyvertrag. Ich habe irgendwo in der Türkei, in so einer Gasse habe ich irgendwo so einen Handyvertrag abgeschlossen, der nimmt mich aus. Das ist gnadenlos. Und für jedes SMS, den du verschickst, wird ein Schwein geköpft oder so. Ja, genau. Muss ich irgendwie ein Schwein an seinen Vater zahlen? Also es kostet 8,50 Euro pro SMS. Ich habe das nicht ganz durchdrungen, aber so ist es halt jetzt. Und ein MMS kostet ein Rind oder sowas. Okay, wir haben das Ding vielleicht ein bisschen stoppaziert. Aber was hast du für Fragen gestellt? So ganz persönliche Fragen, also so Relationship Advice und so ganz simple Dinge irgendwie, keine Ahnung. Aber ganz ehrlich, sind die Leute, die da arbeiten, die den ganzen Tag Dinge von Leuten beantworten oder helfen, sind das Leute, denen man eine Beziehungsfrage stellen will? Ich weiß es nicht, aber es ist zumindest einfach mal ein anderer Mensch, mit dem man reden kann, was ja auch ganz okay ist. Mir und einem Kollegen wurde gleichzeitig eine gewisse Lea zugeteilt. Ja, ich habe auch Lea. Okay, wir haben alle Lea. Lea ist also, GoButter ist ein Mensch, Lea. Er könnte auch GoLea heißen, aber es wäre langweilig. Und die ist 24 Stunden, sieben Tage die Woche, für uns da. Glaubst du, dass man ihr Beziehungsfragen stellen sollte? Ich weiß nicht, aber ich kann mir auch gut vorstellen, dass es einfach Lea durch die Marktforschung gegangen ist und als der sympathisch klingendste Name überhaupt rausgekommen ist. Deswegen heißt er einfach jeder Lea. Und egal, ob du Ahmed, Dimitri oder Agathe bist, du heisst einfach bei... Aber wer ist da nicht wer ist dann nicht schlauer, irgendwie Ali zu nehmen, so einen Namen, den man per se nicht traut erst mal. Ja, genau. Um dann möglichst wenig Aufträge zu bekommen, um möglichst wenig Aufwand zu haben. Gut, man würde auch weniger Geld verdienen, aber weniger Aufwand zu haben, unter dem Strich. Ja, wo man dann positiv überrascht ist, wenn es tatsächlich funktioniert. Das ist, glaube ich, ein psychologisch besserer Effekt als von Lea, weil Lea kann man nur enttäuscht werden, weil Lea klingt einfach wie ein Engel und die klingt einfach so, als könnte sie dir jeden Wunsch erfüllen und wenn es dann nicht klappt, dann bist du eher enttäuscht.
Ich habe eben schon dreimal das Wort per se benutzt heute, also die Wörter per se.
Was ist eigentlich dein Lieblings lateinischer Begriff?
Quad era demonstrandum oder auch salve einfach. Salve.
Ist manchmal so eine coole Version, um Hallo zu sagen.
Salve. Das finden alle sympathisch.
Latein ist echt die unsympathische
Sprache der Welt.
Gut, sie gibt's nicht mehr, wahrscheinlich weil sie einfach zu unsympathisch war.
Ja, wahrscheinlich schon.
Die Leute haben einfach alle Leute gehasst, die Latein gesprochen haben.
Ja, genau.
Der Nachbar ruft über die Hecke Salve, ja, scheiss, besser,
verpiss dich einfach.
Fick dich deine scheiss Sprache.
Nullerpöne sie ne Legge.
Ja, halt die Fresse, du Spast.
Quilla subsole Iacet.
Ja, mein Gott, dann liegt sie halt unter der Sonne,
die scheiss Villa. Wen juckt es denn?
Alia Jacta Est. Ja, ich weiß,
wir spielen seit drei Stunden
Mensch, ärgere dich nicht. Das musst du jetzt nicht jedes Mal sagen, du Idiot. So was in der Richtung. Vene Vidi Vici. Okay, cooler Spruch. Das ist der coolste Spruch eigentlich. Es ist der coolste Spruch und er ist auch einfach badass. Ich glaube, wer auch immer das war, Asterix hat damals einfach badass-tum definiert mit diesem Satz einfach. Vene Vidi Vici, Knallhack. Sehr gut. Platz zwei oder eins der Dinge, die man nicht im Interview fragen sollte? Gibt es eine App, mit der man Interviews lernen kann? Ich finde, eine sehr hoch platzierte Frage ist meiner Meinung nach, was ist der letzte Verwandte, der von dir gestorben ist? Und was glaubst du, ist der Nächste?
Das ist eigentlich die wichtigste Frage. Wen würdest du lieber töten?
Ein Nazi oder fünf Panda-Babys?
Irgendwie sowas.
Ja, bei welchen deiner Geschwister wärst du am wenigsten traurig, wenn sie sterben würde?
Nicht Marc, nicht Marc, den schließen wir mal aus.
Das ist ja klar, aber welcher sonst noch?
Man hat auch sehr gut recherchiert vor diesem schlechten Interview. Ja, bleibt da nur noch einer übrig. Sind sie adoptiert? Warum nicht? Glaubst du, wenn so ein Tausendfüßler einen Heiratsantrag macht, dauert doch auch ewig, oder? Dass er erst mal auf alle Knie gegangen ist? Das sind diese Gags, wo ich dir dann gar nicht mehr zurückschreiben würde. Also ich will mal dieses geile Bewertungsmodell, wo ich ihm einfach eine Zahl zwischen 1 und 10 und wenn ich dir einen Gag schreibe, sagst du mir eine Zahl zwischen 1 und 10, aber das wäre so ein Gag, wo ich entweder gar nicht zurückschreiben würde und hoffe, dass es vergisst oder selber draufkommt, dass es scheisse ist, oder wo ich einfach nein, einfach nein zurückschreiben würde. Aber die Vorstellung von so einem Tausendfüßler, der dem anderen Tausendfüßler ganz tief in die Augen schaut, dann geht er auf ein Knie, zweites Knie, drittes Knie, viertes Knie, der weibliche Tausendfüßler schaut schon so auf die Uhr, so okay, ja, und dann dauert es halt einfach noch eine halbe Stunde. Geil, weil dann der Move, bis der weibliche Tausendfüßler dann einfach nein sagt. Ja, genau, und dann geht ihr langsam wieder ein Knie nach dem anderen Dann geht wieder hoch, ja. Und dann dauert es halt einfach noch eine halbe Stunde. Geil, weil dann der Move, bis der beibliche Tausendfüßler einfach Nein sagt. Ja, genau. Und dann geht ihr langsam wieder ein, Knie nach dem anderen geht wieder hoch. Ist ein guter Gag, könnte man als Comic-Zeit. Man hat als Tausendfüßler dann auch sehr lange Zeit, die Ehe zu überdenken. So jedes Jahr, die ganze Zukunft durchzugehen. Und ich glaube, wir deswegen halten auch im Schnitt Tausendfüßler Ehen wesentlich länger. Es Ist das schon sehr erwiesen. Gut, hau mal mehr so.
Das klappt anscheinend sehr gut.
Hau mal mehr Gags raus.
Den tollen Witz
habe ich mir gerade ausgedacht.
Ach nee,
den kann man nicht erzählen, den braucht man ein Setting.
Angenommen, also der Witz wäre lustig,
wenn ich Physik studieren würde.
Okay, angenommen, du stehst für die Physik.
Okay, das ist dasik, was man braucht.
Hey, habt ihr mitbekommen,
heute war ein Krankenwagen da.
Hat wohl jemand versucht,
durch Null zu teilen?
Der ist nicht so scheiße.
Vor allem,
was es für mich interessant macht, ist,
dass ich weiss, dass du schon seit drei Wochen einen Durch-Null-Teilen-Gag brainstormst.
Vor drei Wochen hast du mir das erste Mal einen Gag zum Thema Durch-Null-Teilen gemacht.
Und ich weiss, dass du seit drei Wochen daran arbeitest. Und das ist der Gag, der jetzt dabei rausgekommen ist?
Ich habe nicht mehr lange darüber nachgedacht, höchstens noch eine Woche oder so.
Dann habe ich es aber auch versucht, an Akta zu legen. Aber das ist das, was am Ende rauskam.
Ich glaube, du verstehst es einfach nicht. Doch, ich glaube, ich verstehe es schon. Okay. Ist es bei dir, du... Was? Ist es bei dir, du... Kann ich das als Handy-Klingelton haben, bitte? Ah, übrigens. Für die SMS einfach, dibbibbibbdu. Letztes Mal, letztes Mal habe ich unsere Folge geschnitten und da war so ein extrem geiler Lacher von dir drin. Den hätte man so nehmen können und der wäre irgendwie Worldwide Trending gewesen in jedem scheiß Portal. Irgendwie so ganz geil hast du dich gesteigert beim Lachen. Auch die Waveform davon war schon ein Gag. Die Waveform dieses Lachers war schon geil. Das ist eigentlich schon ganz gut, wenn die Waveform alleine schon ein Lacher ist. Kannst du mal raushauen als Screenshot, du kannst dir den Lacher jetzt mal reinschneiden. Fick dich, Alter. Ihr habt keinen Bock auf so eine scheisse Zusatzarbeit. Genau wie letztes Mal, wo wir uns eigentlich überlegt hatten, so einen geilen Trennermusik zu nehmen für unsere Rubrik. Und ich habe es einfach nicht gemacht. Ich habe aber dieses Laberei drin gelassen. Ja, ich finde den Gag aber besser, wenn man das nicht extra erwähnt, dass du es nicht gemacht hast. Also das würde ich jetzt rausschneiden. Vielleicht sollten wir einfach aufhören, unsere Gags zu erklären. Ja, oder wir sollten einfach aufhören, Gags zu machen. Hast du mal eigentlich Lust auf so eine ganz ernste Folge? Ja, die Frage ist halt, ob wir ernst was zu sagen haben. Also es ist ja immer, ich habe da ja immer so viel Respekt davor, vor ernsten Botschaften, weil ich mir immer denke, ich habe halt einfach keine Ahnung von gar nichts. Und auch so tiefgründige philosophische Tweets und so motivational Tweets habe ich immer das Gefühl so, ja, ich erzähle da Scheiße und Arroganz und tue da irgendwie so, als wäre ich tiefgründig und toll, was ich nicht bin. Und deswegen habe ich da immer so viel Respekt davor und so viel Hemmung,
irgendwie dann da ins Ernste
zu gehen, weil es oft halt einfach Bullshit ist.
Vor allem bei ernsten Dingen,
bei ernsten Dingen muss halt auch viel dahinterstecken, da müssen sehr viele
Gedanken dahinterstecken, die man sich darüber gemacht hat.
Und wenn man halt unernst
über ein Thema redet, dann kann man auch einfach mal ein Klischee benutzen
und alle denken sich, ja, der hat sich bestimmt Gedanken
darüber gemacht. Aber oft ist es einfach nur so, dass man einfach faul ist, sich wirklich Gedanken zu machen über ein Thema redest, da kann man auch einfach mal ein Klischee benutzen. Und alle denken sich, ja, der hat sich bestimmt Gedanken darüber gemacht.
Aber oft ist es einfach nur so, dass man einfach faul ist, sich wirklich Gedanken zu machen über ein Thema, sich wirklich mit etwas auseinanderzusetzen und eine ernste Meinung zu vertreten, weil eine Lustige dann einfach zu unemotional ist. Ja, aber da kommen wir zu dem Thema, das ich in der letzten Folge gesagt habe, dass man halt immer die Überzeugung hat, dass das, was man sagen müsste, halt irgendwie so einen ewigen Wert haben müsste. Dass man, wenn ich jetzt irgendwie mein großes Weltbild, meine Theorie der zwischenmenschlichen Kommunikation ausbreite, dass es halt so einen ewigen, harten Wert haben könnte. Aber es ist halt ein Bullshit. Man rät halt zu 95 Prozent am Tag Bullshit. So gut wie alles, was man sagt, ist Schwachsinn. Und müsste man eigentlich irgendwann wieder zurückziehen, wenn man nur genug Zeit hätte, alles wieder zurückziehen zu können, was man so den ganzen Tag sagt, weil es ist halt alles einfach nur Freestyle und improvisiert und davon ist nicht viel da und deswegen, wenn man jetzt irgendwie so gross Lebensphilosophien erzählt und wie sollte man sein und wie sollte man nicht sein, das ist halt alles Bullshit einfach. Ich habe mir damals immer gewünscht, oder in der Zeit meines Lebens habe ich mir gewünscht, eine Maschine zu haben, die mir alle Fragen beantworten kann und da habe ich besonders über die Fragen nachgedacht oder die Antworten darüber nachgedacht, was sie dir sagen würde, wenn man fragen würde, was ist das Lustigste, was ich jemals gesagt habe? Zum Beispiel, was ist das dümmste, was ich jemals gesagt habe? Was ist das rassistischste, was ich jemals gesagt habe? Das sind so geile Fragen, wo man sich nachdenkt, was ist das wirklich? Ja, so eine Statistik. Ja, genau. Dass dein ganzes Leben eine Statistik geführt wird, auch irgendwie, wie viel Prozent meiner Gags haben Lacher erzeugt. Oder einfach so knallharte Prozentzahlen. Sowas fände ich total interessant. Der wieviel coolste Mensch auf der Welt bin ich? Ja, genau. Von unten. Einfach mal. Ja. Aber das ist auch eine coole. Also so eine Maschine, wenn die mal jemand bauen könnte, ganz kurz vielleicht, wäre das für mich ein Riesending. Ich würde das echt feiern. Ja, weiss ich nicht. Man will halt Sicherheit irgendwo haben. Man ist halt, der Mensch kann halt nicht so gut mit Unsicherheit umgehen. Und halt, glaube ich, solche objektiven Sachen. Der Mensch braucht Fakten. Der Mensch braucht objektive Fakten. Der Mensch braucht objektive Fakten und gerade bei solchen Selbsteinschätzungssachen ist es halt immer sehr gut, Feedback zu bekommen und gesagt zu bekommen, hey, so und so
ist es und so und so ist es, weil man selber halt mit
der Unsicherheit oft nicht gut umgehen kann,
weil Unsicherheit oft das Schlimmste ist.
Mir wurde gesagt, wir sind so eine Art Philosophie-Podcast
sogar. Also wir würden
die meiste Zeit einfach
ziemlich traditionell
philosophieren. Und da habe ich darüber
nachgedacht und ich bin zum Schluss gekommen, es stimmt auf eine Art ja auch, also wir reden immer über Glückseligkeit, über Humor, wir reden darüber, also diese Maschinen, die man sich vorstellt, die einem alle Fragen beantworten kann, ist ja auch ein hochphilosophisches Modell eigentlich. Bestimmt, also vielleicht hat sich da immer schon mal Gedanken drüber gemacht, vielleicht sind wir bei iTunes auch falsch aufgehoben bei Humor. Vielleicht sollten wir uns langsam zu Philosophie hocharbeiten. Oder Technik, Technik-Podcast. Oder zu Poesie, das ist ja sowieso auch immer das Beste. Ich glaube, wir werden super Technik-Podcast. Ich glaube, wir können super, wir könnten super gut einfach Leuten Technik erklären. Ach Mensch, wir als Menschen schweben verloren durchs Universum, wissen nicht wohin. Aber es ist nicht, ich habe es bei jedem Menschen so, nur die meisten Menschen machen keinen Podcast, wo sie eine Stunde lang über sich reden müssen einfach. Wir haben uns ja auch die Schwierigkeit gemacht, uns in den Mittelpunkt des Podcasts zu stellen und nicht... Hätten wir nicht machen sollen. Wir hätten irgendwie Leute einladen sollen oder irgendwie über die neue Game of Thrones-Folge hätten wir reden sollen, anstatt dass wir ständig über uns selbst reden müssen. Es war wieder ein Fehler, das Thema war immer wieder ein Fehler. Chancen, bezieht man so... Chancen waren scheiß Thema. Es gibt keine Chancen. Das Gute ist, dass wir mittlerweile schon so reflektiert sind, dass wir erkennen, wenn Themen scheiße sind, sie aber trotzdem als Thema nehmen. Auch nicht ändern, ja. Und einfach ins offene Messer laufen. Ich kann kurz die Konversation vorlesen. Ich habe geschrieben, wollen wir vielleicht über Chancen reden? Du hast gesagt, oh nee, das ist ein scheiß Thema und jetzt sitzen wir hier und reden über Chancen.
Wie dumm sind wir eigentlich? Wir sind wie Hühner in Käfighaltung, die nicht erkennen, dass sie ein scheiß Leben haben. Was ich mir heute überlegt habe, ob der normale Mensch, der Durchschnittsmensch, eher denkt, er ist normal oder eher denkt, er ist nicht normal. Also es gibt ja immer so diese Motivational Posts und Tweets hier von wegen, irgendwie jeder hat seine Fehler, jeder ist irgendwie ein bisschen komisch im Innern, jeder hat so seine Makel und so und jeder ist auf seine Art so ein bisschen crazy und es ist okay. Aber ich weiß nicht, ob es wirklich so ist, dass der normale Mensch nicht davon ausgeht, dass er irgendwie komisch ist oder krank ist. Also diese klassische Botschaft
von Freud, irgendwie jeder ist irgendwie im Innersten
komplett pervers und hat irgendwie
komplett abgefahrene Fetische
und ist total freaky. Und ist latent
homosexuell. Ist latent homosexuell
und will mit seiner Mutter schlafen
und kann das aber nicht so rauslassen und wird halt
von der Gesellschaft unterdrückt. Aber ich weiß nicht, ob
die meisten Menschen es wirklich so sehen.
Also ob sie im tiefsten Innern denken, dass sie wirklich einfach richtig abgefuckt sind. Ich glaube ja. Oder denken sie, ich bin eigentlich ganz okay. Ich glaube wirklich, dass jeder Mensch im Innersten denkt, dass er bekloppt ist und es auch zum weiten Teil stimmt. Also ich wäre da voll bei Freud, weil ich kann es nicht begründen. Ach Mann, das ist so eine krasse Frage, da hätte man sich jetzt jahrelang Gedanken von drüber machen müssen, um jetzt ein geiles Referat halten zu können. Ja, ich glaube tatsächlich, dass es auch so ist, aber ich weiß nicht, man braucht ja auch ein gewisses Maß an Selbstreflexion. Man merkt es ja auch oft wieder, also da kann man dann immer wieder psychologisch Pro und Kontra Seite geben, aber wenn man dann irgendwie über Fetischen redet und dann die Leute, und wer macht das denn, und das ist ja eklig und so, wo ich mir denke, man hat bestimmt schon mal selber was wesentlich Abartigeres zumindest gedacht oder fantasiert. Von daher hat man wahrscheinlich einfach nicht, muss man sich vor anderen so darstellen, als hätte man das nicht. Aber eigentlich ist es ja schon egal. Gerade das Internet zeigt mir, dass alle Menschen gleich beklopfen sind wie ich. Also ich habe zum Beispiel mal ganz komische Probleme, habe ich manchmal, auch so gesundheitlich, wo man denkt, warum habe ich jetzt genau, ich habe zum Beispiel noch nicht Basketball gespielt, was ein Riesenfehler bei mir ist. Also die Kollegen haben plötzlich gesagt, ja komm, wir werfen ein paar Körbe, ich in meiner Naivität, ja okay, ich bin dabei, Leute, habe auch so versucht, habe auch so versucht, so Basketball-Slang zu sprechen, weil ich halt so ein Method-Actor-Typ bin. Ein paar Hoops, ja. Also, ja, ein bisschen Lines gedroppt, ein bisschen gefreestylt, war ultrapeilig, ultrapeilig, Rebound, ja. Ich habe erst mal einen Korb gedroppt, keine Ahnung, wie man das... Und dann haben wir angefangen, halt richtig zu spielen gegeneinander, also drei gegen drei, und ich war komplett verloren. Ich habe so nach zehn Minuten einfach nichts mehr gespürt. Mein linker Arm war taub, aus irgendeinem Grund. Ich weiß nicht, vielleicht habe ich
bleibende Schäden davongetragen, ich weiß es nicht genau.
Und dann habe ich plötzlich so Druck
unter meinen Füssen gespürt, dann habe ich nach dem Spiel
irgendwann mal die Socken ausgezogen und ich hatte
richtig große Blutblasen
unter meinem Fuss. Also
Sportarten stossen mich
voll ab. Also ich kann da nicht mehr
für, ich war einfach konditionell
schon am Ende und körperlich auch so komische, meine Füsse stossen plötzlich Sport ab anscheinend. Vor allem, warum will der Körper eigentlich keinen Sport haben? Ist es nicht total gesund? So schiesst sich der Körper da nicht selbst ins Bein? Ich glaube, er will Sport haben, der Körper, aber das Hirn halt nicht. Er kann es nicht formulieren, er findet nicht die Worte dafür. Ja, und das ist halt wirklich so komisch. Und dann habe ich das gegoogelt, Blutblasen, und es hatten wirklich sehr, sehr viele andere Menschen das gleiche Problem.
Und dann habe ich auch mal, haben wir mal in der Redaktion für ein Spiel gebrainstormt und überlegt, wäre das nicht geil, wenn wir ein Spiel nehmen, wo Google den Satz vollendet.
Wir machen auch viele andere Late-Night-Shows.
Und dann hat man eingegeben, mein, und dann ist das dritte oder so, mein Bauchnabel stinkt.
Das heißt, eine signifikante Anzahl von Menschen muss man gegoogelt haben, mein Bauchnabel stinkt.
Vielen Dank. hat mal eingegeben, mein, und dann ist das dritte oder so, mein Bauchnabel stinkt. Das heißt, eine signifikante Anzahl von Menschen muss man gegoogelt haben, mein Bauchnabel stinkt. Ich glaube... Ja, oder es war einfach die letzte Suchanfrage von unserem Redaktionsleiter. Kann auch sein. Von mir. Fällt mir gerade ein. Da habe ich nämlich Volleyball gespielt, da plötzlich fühlt man Bauchnabel anzustinken. Ja, aber das sind so Dinge, ich glaube, das Internet hilft einem da sehr.
Es ist da sehr therapeutisch, wirkt es da, weil einfach jeder Mensch irgendwie auf eine Art seine Probleme hat und dann nicht ganz klar kommt und dann aber auch froh ist, im Internet andere Dinge zu entdecken, andere Leute zu entdecken, die gleiche Probleme haben. Ja, stimmt. Aber gut, die Aussage war jetzt auch nicht so bahnbrechend. Das meine ich halt, man unterhält sich dann, aber die Aussage ist halt, jeder ist ein bisschen komisch und das ist okay. Aber da hättest du jetzt auch einen Motivationspost lesen können auf Facebook. Aber sie ist auch nicht so bahnbrechend. Mir ist gerade aufgefallen, ich habe gerade während du geredet, einfach angefangen, bei WhatsApp zu scrollen und bei Twitter zu gucken. So weit ist es schon, dass ich während des Podcasts plötzlich mein Handy raushole. Das ist eigentlich so die einzige Stunde in der Woche, wo ich mich wirklich nur aufs Sprechen konzentriere sonst eigentlich. Selbst das ist nicht mehr gegeben. Es fährt alles den Bach runter. Ich weiß auch nicht, ob wir das noch lange machen sollen. Die Themen sind offensichtlich aus. Wir selber als Menschen geben. Wir sollten uns einfach nur mal ein bisschen mehr als eine Minute Zeit nehmen, um nach Themen zu suchen und nicht bei einem Thema, was wir selber schon als schlecht abtun, stehen bleiben. Ich habe wahnsinnig viele Themen vorgeschlagen, die du alle abgeben hast. Du hast kein Thema vorgeschlagen, du hast genau null Themen vorgeschlagen. Weil es ein gutes Thema ist. 50-50, ja dann lass uns darüber reden. Hey, wir haben nur 13 Minuten. Zeig mal wie toll, du breitest dich darauf vor, auf das, was du in den letzten 47 Minuten abgeliefert hast, hat das dich vorbereitet? Nein. Klein, so ganz kleiner, nein, nein, Herr Tietz. Wir sollten mal vielleicht so eine Weltreise machen einfach, wo wir ganz viele Dinge erleben. Einfach neue Erfahrungen sammeln. Wo wir einfach auch sehr, so ein Messerschneide, bis es schon so Richtung Lebensgefahr geht, immer Dinge erleben, damit wir geile Storys zu erzählen haben, sondern wir sind nach zwei Wochen tot, aber haben bis dahin geile Storys zu erzählen. Also, es ist auch so ein Ding. Ich weiß nicht, ob es das bringt, ich glaube, es ist eher eine innere Reise, die wir brauchen. Wir müssen uns einfach als Menschen ein bisschen mehr kennenlernen. Ja, genau, innere Reise oder einfach so Gedankenexperimente wagen. Sich selbst finden, ja. Und Gags in Gedankenexperimenten suchen. Also wir können uns das mal vorstellen, können wir mal ein Hörbuch aufnehmen innerhalb des Podcasts, warum mal die Idee? Ja, so eine kleine Geschichte, einfach ein bisschen improvisieren. Okay, und go. Gib mir ein Setting, gib mir ein Setting. Ähm, Zoo. Okay, aber... Ne, wir fangen an, wir fangen im Zoo an, einfach so. Okay, ich bin... Okay, wir sind hier im Zoo und wir haben es sicherhin ja geschafft. Wir haben endlich... Wir müssen die Tiere befreien. Wir müssen die Tiere befreien. Hey, Markus, da bist du ja.
Wo warst du so lange?
Ich wusste nicht, dass ich die auch finde.
Wir haben doch gesagt, wir verabreden uns am Affengehege.
Warum bist du jetzt hier? Ich habe mich in die Flamingos verliebt. Die gucken so süss.
Es geht heute nicht um die Flamingos, Markus.
Wir wollen uns heute um die Fledermäuse kümmern und nur um die Fledermäuse.
Aber warum genau, das hat mich von vornherein nicht verstanden.
Warum genau wollten wir uns dann bei den Affen treffen?
Damit es nicht so auffällig ist.
Wenn wir jetzt die ganze Zeit mit diesem riesigen Wollsack hier vor den Fledermäusern stehen, dann fällt es jedem auf.
Okay, also los, komm.
Hast du den Sack dabei?
Ja, habe ich dabei.
Gut, okay, dann lass uns kurz rübergehen, aber sei nicht so auffällig, okay?
Fledermäuse, wir gehen nur zu den Fledermäusen. Hallo, guten Abend.
Hallo, wir gehen nur zu den Fledermäusen. Guten Tag, hallo, wir wollen nur die Fledermäuse be wir gehen nur zu den Fledermäusen. Hallo, guten Abend, hallo, wir gehen nur zu den Fledermäusen.
Guten Tag, hallo, wir wollen nur die Fledermäuse befreien, keine Angst. Also, naja, wir wollen es nur anschauen, ich meine, die sind ja frei, auf eine gewisse Art, es reicht ja an Freiheit, es muss ja nicht mehr. Die können ja fliegen, ich meine, wer kann ja nicht fliegen, also wenn wer schon fliegen kann, dann muss er auch nicht. Aber wir können nicht sehen, also es ist ja auch so. Ich bin auch gar nicht nervös, weil wir Fledermäuse befreien. Nein, aber auch wenn wir sehen könnten, würden wir sie... Also es ist ja nicht so, dass sie jetzt besonders einfach zu fangen wären, weil sie nicht sehen können. Das ist ja zu kurz gedacht. Nicht wahr? Ja, Maulwürfe hingegen können gar nicht sehen. Die müsste man sich gar nicht befreien, weil die wissen ja eh nicht, wo sie gerade sind. Ja, aber wenn man sich jetzt entscheiden müsste, welche Tiere müsste man klauen, Fledermäuse oder Maulwürfe, dann wären Maulwürfel die bessere Entscheidung. Wir sind schon dreimal an dem Hegel vorbeigelaufen, wir sollten vielleicht mal hingehen. Wir sollten uns ein Eis kaufen, wir sollten uns erst ein Eis kaufen. Ich habe ein bisschen Angst vor diesem Soft-Eis, ich habe immer Angst, dass Salmonellen... Aber ich will das Soft-Eis mit Schokolade, wir fragen mal. Okay. Ja, guten Tag, was hätten Sie denn gerne? Ja, ich hätte gerne Soft-Eis... Wir hätten Eis für Sie, muahaha, weil es ja so heiß ist hier draußen. Da können Sie sich ein bisschen erfrischen. Da hat mein Kollege Recht, wir sind zwei Leute am Eisstand, weil wir... Obwohl es eigentlich nur einer wollte. Es gab nur eine Stelle, aber wir sind auch mit dem halben Gehalt zufrieden. Ich wollte nur sagen, in dem Eis, das müssen wir Ihnen vorher mitteilen, sind Fledermausreste. Ist das okay? Aber die kann man nicht sehen, verstehen Sie? Weil man Fledermäuse auch, also weil Fledermäuse nicht sehen kann. Äh, okay. Ja gut, dann hätte ich gerne einmal mit Schokolade, bitte. Moment, ganz kurz. Wir müssen uns ganz kurz beraten. Ja, ist kein Problem. Ja, ähm. Kein Problem, kommen Sie gleich wieder, Sie finden ja zurück, weil Sie können ja sehen. Ganz kurz, da sind jetzt genau Federmäus-Reste drin. Wir wollten Tiere befreien. Warum kommen die da rein? Ich habe Bock auf dem Eis. Das können wir nicht machen. Wir machen uns selbst mitverantwortlich für diesen Massenmord, der hier stattfindet. Wir machen uns mitverantwortlich, das geht nicht. Aber wir können jetzt auch nicht zurückziehen. Aber wir können... Dann nehmen wir zusammen ein Eis. Aber wir können nicht zusammen am selben Eis necken. Ja, wir hätten gerne ein Eis im Becher. Ja, was hätten wir denn gerne? Haben Sie wieder zurückgefunden? Haben Sie uns wieder gesehen? Mit zwei Löffeln. Das ist ein komischer Kerl. Ein Eis mit zwei Löffeln? Ja, ist das so... Ginge das? Das ist sehr ungewöhnlich. Das macht Sie verdächtig. Ja, es ist aber nicht... Wollen sie sich nicht nochmal zur Beratung zurückziehen? Ja, vielleicht doch. Ich würde gerne diese Chancen nutzen. Wir kommen gleich nochmal. Okay. Dem ist das total aufgefallen. Ja, du hast auch gesagt, das ist verdächtig. Du hättest das Wir-wollen-Fledermäuse-befreien-T-Shirt einfach nicht anziehen sollen heute. Du hättest das heute einmal nicht anziehen. Das einzige weisse T-Shirt, das ich habe. Es ist so heiß. Hast du eine Ah wie heiß es ist? fuck ey komm beginn nochmal okay also das ist hallo da sitzt sie wieder haben sie eine bessere Entscheidung getroffen die nicht so auffällig ist ja wir hätten gerne einfach zwei Eis bitte zwei Eis das ist sehr unauffällig die meisten Leute nehmen ein Eis pro Person genau wie sie welche Geschmacksrechnung werden? okay ich hätte gerne Zitronen-Eis einmal Zit Zitronen-Eis. Hugo, mach einmal Zitronen-Eis. Okay. Verdammt. Und für Sie. Das Zitronen-Eis ist alle. Wir haben nur noch generell nur noch kein Eis mehr, fällt mir gerade auf. Der Zoo macht auch jetzt zu. Dieses Gespräch hat schon vor fünf Minuten aufgehört, lustig zu sein. Also lass uns einfach das Eis geben und dieses Hörspiel beenden.
Aber es gibt auch noch eine ganze Menge Plot zu erledigen. Was ist denn jetzt mit dem Plot, der angeteasert wurde im Akt 1? Wir sind ja noch nicht mal in Akt 2. Aber es fühlt sich an wie Akt 7.
Na gut, also, meine Herren, wir haben jetzt leider geschlossen, aber hier ist noch ein Mangolassi für euch beide.
Dankeschön, dankeschön.
Ja, dankeschön.
Endcredits.
Wobei der Text ist nicht ganz richtig, der Text der Text heißt auf Deutsch, ich bereue
nichts. Oh, sehr gut, stimmt.
Wenn man auch nicht mehr, ja, okay. Ja, sehr geehrte Zuhörerinnen und Zuhörer, das war Folge 18. Wir haben damit die Vorjährigkeit erreicht, mit all seiner Scham, seiner unangenehmen Momenten, seinen Awkward Moments, wo man durchmacht. Ab Folge 21 fangen wir an zu zocken. Sag ich ja. Genau. Und ab Folge 25 fangen wir an, über Sex zu reden. Und ab Folge 34 fangen wir an, so ein bisschen benommen auf unser Leben zurückzuschauen. Und ab Folge 89 sind wir nicht mehr in der Lage, irgendwie auszudrücken, was wir gerade empfinden, und werden immer im Zwei-Minuten-Takt uns selber wiederholen, bis so ein Loop. Viel Spaß bis dahin, ansonsten wir haben 17 andere tolle Folgen, die ihr euch anhören könnt, außer Folge 12 und Folge 6. Ey, warte mal! Was denn? Ey, Folge 6, 12 und 18 sind schlecht! Bum! Oder? Und da liegt jeweils ein Abstand von 6 dazwischen, dreimal die 6, also wir wissen genau, wen wir diese Scheiße zu verdacht haben.
Das ist ja krass.
Das ist wirklich krass, oder?
Falls ihr wissen wollt, wie es mit den beiden Helden im Zoo weitergeht, dann schaltet
doch das nächste Mal wieder ein.
Mich selber interessiert das überhaupt gar nicht.
Hast du das Gefühl, also müssen Autoren selber der Meinung, müssen selber...
Nein, überhaupt nicht.
Nein.
Glaube ich nicht.
Man hat gedanklich, man hat alle Chancen, man kann alles machen theoretisch, man kann über alles sprechen, alles kann passieren. Man kann jetzt wirklich eine Breaking-Bad-eske Gangstergeschichte aufbauen, die extrem fest ist. Und selbst in unserer Welt, wo alles möglich ist, erleben wir so eine langweilige Story, von der man abends auch nicht auf der Party erzählen würde. Es hätte einen Drache, es hätte einen Drache vorbeifliegen würde und wir erleben eine Story, die man selbst, die ich selbst, wenn ich so erleben würde, niemandem erzählen würde, weil sie so peinlich ist. Selbst in unserer Fantasie sind wir die uncoolsten Typen der Welt. Selbst wenn wir alle Möglichkeiten haben, entscheiden wir uns für Langeweile, für ein langweiliges Leben, in dem nichts passiert. Diese Pointe war die Schwerte, die war so eine zehn Minuten lange Rampe für eine Pointe, die ganz okay war eigentlich. Aber auch so eine Story, die immer langweiliger wird. Sie beginnt mit Spannung und Spaß, aber endet dann einfach in kompletter Belanglosigkeit und hört dann auch auf. Hört dann vor dem Act Break einfach auf. Wenn der Spannungsbogen einfach falsch rum ist. Wenn man sich den Spannungsbogen von der falschen Seite anguckt. Ja, genau, so eine Verfolgungsjagd, die immer langsamer wird. Wenn man mit Platz 1 anfängt und bei Platz 5 aufhört. Das ist, glaube ich, ziemlich genau. Das Podcast-UFO, warum nicht. Jetzt wisst ihr, warum wir uns für diesen Slogan entschieden haben. Letztendlich, ja, mein Gott, Leute, kippet das Podcast-UFO, wir sehen uns nächste Woche wieder mit einer guten Folge, in sechs Folgen kann man jetzt schon sagen, hört lieber nicht rein. Da laden wir wieder einen Gast ein. Ja, genau, damit wir noch eine dritte Person in unser Schlammloch mit reinziehen. Ich denke, wir kriegen aus dieser Grütze, aus diesem Schwall, den wir heute hier vor uns gegeben haben, aus diesem Konglomerat aus undefinierbarem Schwachsinn, eine Folge zusammenbekommen, die länger ist als eine halbe Stunde, kürzer ist als eine Stunde, die aber trotzdem Leute sich anhören können. Ich würde deswegen kurz einfach eine Verabschiedung sagen. Also ich werde dich nicht hochladen, ohne Witz. Es ist mir halt egal, du kannst ja schneiden, so viele Witz, aber ich werde dich nicht hochladen. Ich werde mich persönlich bei jedem einzelnen Hörer erstmal entschuldigen und dann sich vielleicht hochladen. Du willst dich so schützen, vor die Folge werfen. Und ich versuche die Zuhörer abzulenken. Ich versuche bei jedem einzelnen Zuhörer von den allen acht und zwanzig, die wir haben, irgendwie eine Briefbombe zu platzieren oder dass irgendwie ein Autounfall vor der Haustür stattfindet, damit sie abgelenkt sind, wenn die Folge hochgeladen wird. Und dann schleiche ich mich in deren Wohnung und lösche die Folge, sodass niemand jemals weiss, dass sie stattgefunden hat. Das ist mein Plan. Deswegen, wenn ihr in der nächsten Zeit einen fetten, hässlichen Typen seht, der an eurer Tür irgendwie rumrüttelt, das könnte Stefan sein. Das ist Dirk Bach. Das ist wahrscheinlich Dirk Bach, der versucht, aus eurem Keller zu fliehen.
Das war's, das Podcast-UFO, die Volljährigkeit, juhu, endlich erwachsen, wow.
Nächste Woche geht's richtig steil, da erzählen wir von interessantem.
Ja, vielen Dank und das Podcast-UFO hebt ab in eine besseren Welt.
Eieiei.
Oh Mann, immer dieses gute Folge-Schläge-Folgeding.
Die Olippee-Folge war okay, und die letzte Folge war auch okay.
Die letzte Folge war richtig gut.
Echt? Fandest du mittlerweile? Hast du noch mal gehört?